[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and i'm so glad we
live in a society where zack snyder's
justice league is finally getting
released
one of the most intriguing things about
the director's vision
is his nightmare timeline which
showcases the earth decimated by
darkseid
and an evil superman so bad that
homelander would go back to sucking his
mother's milk
[Music]
you made my day
[Music]
first shone in batman v superman this
dark and alternate future
is what would have happened to our world
had joss whedon's version of the movie
remain canon
i'm going to be breaking it all down in
the video after piecing most things
together from the original outlines
and interviews on snyder's work it's a
really great storyline and the aesthetic
even made for a halloween costume that i
once
wore all the way back before the world
was ruined
now before starting this i feel we need
to lay out the original structure of
zack's dc eu
as it kind of makes things easier to
understand i'm also going to be talking
about a lot of timey whiny wibbly wobbly
stuff
which will sort of change the layout of
things as we go through it but from the
top we need to just look at the events
as if they're traveling in a straight
line
our timeline starts with man of steel
and originally in the movie there were
meant to be elements that established
and built upon the idea that every
member of krypton
was devoid of free will as clark was
born naturally
he didn't have a predetermined path that
he was placed on and very much
represented a shift in society
jor-el gave him the codex which
contained information on the entirety of
krypton civilization
and thus he became the future for the
planet our timeline then follows the
events of man of steel
which of course ended with the death of
zod at the hands of superman
we then jumped a batman v superman and
the aftermath of the two kryptonians
fight
we see a troubled dark knight who
decides that superman is an alien
that he must take down before he
destroys the planet
in the original timeline the pair go
head to head and batman almost kills him
however they become the super marthio
brothers after batman sees
that they have a lot in common
unfortunately their friendship is cut
shorter than jeff jones's career when
doomsday kills clark
after being awoken by lex luther justice
league then takes place
and we learn about our axis of
apocalypse and his failed invasion of
earth
which happened millennia ago when prince
philip was young
dwarted by the heroes at the time he
cast his uncle steppenwolf out
who returns to earth after learning of
superman's death from lex
steppenwolf's plan is to reclaim three
mother boxes which will allow him to
cast a wave of fear
alienation and doubt over the planet
this will fuel the already existing
depression over the passing of the man
of steel
and make earth feel like 2020 all over
again
wait isn't isn't that just 2021 anyway
in the original timeline bruce forms the
justice league and they resurrect clark
who is able to come back because of the
codex within his cells
they managed to stop steppenwolf from
terraforming the planet
and wonder woman beheads him and then
throws it into a boom tube
which is when the heroes see darkseid on
the other end
he stares back at them they stare back
at him
they then stare back some more and he
stares back even more than they stared
back
and either way you slice it up it's own
diana then starts to research who this
mysterious figure is
a martian manhunter visits bruce at his
lake house which is where we learn that
he's actually general swanwick
thanks thanks for helping out in the
doomsday fight mate much much
appreciated
he also introduces bruce to the green
lanterns and we discover that they
protect the universe from threats like
darkseid
from here on out batman begins to grow
anxious over the incoming invasion
and it's not too long before things
start going to hell
in the original timeline the heroes all
unite and decide to communicate with the
lanterns in order to formulate a plan
clark learns that lois is pregnant with
his child and before you can even ask
why he didn't use a kryptonite condom
he's convinced by batman to join the
fight batman promises that he'll keep
lois safe at his lake house
and she remains there with alfred the
league leaves it
and through the flying fox they travel
to new genesis in order to meet with the
people of it
and the green lantern corps armed with a
bunch of new allies the heroes storm
apocalypse
but darkseid makes them look worse than
cging out superman's mustache
and he destroys their only ways of
returning to earth
the villain also captures superman and
strips the codex from him
and he begins to study it darkseid
learns that because the kryptonians were
able to obliterate free will amongst
their people
that he can adopt this as a weapon and
take over the universe
using all that he learns he creates the
anti-life equation
and journeys to earth where he decimates
the planet because of the fear and
anguish that this causes the majority of
the population succumb to the anti-life
equation
and slowly the villain is able to turn
the majority of them into parademons
on apocalypse the heroes rescue clock
and manage to fix their ship
which allows them to travel back to
earth but on the way
most of them turn against batman they
just think the guy's an idiot at this
point
upon reaching their home they witnessed
the destruction and clarkland said
darkseid murdered lois in his unborn
child
after seeing the obliteration of another
one of his homes
the loss of his father mother lois and
his kid
he falls into a deep depression the
anti-life equation
slowly starts to seep into his way of
thinking and clark turns into a bad guy
faster than joss whedon did i'm a bit
unsure of the order of the next spot
so i'll tell you the two ways that
things can be taken
the first option we have is that batman
discovers deathstroke is alive
using him in cyborg they track down the
joker and get a mother box from him
which will hopefully help in defeating
darkseid the heroes are able to end the
villain's reign and out of nowhere
superman kills him superman then takes
over his army and some of the survivors
of earth begin to worship him
and even get little little patches for
their uniform which is nice
and batman obviously doesn't like this
and he turns against him creating a
small rebellion in the process that
planned to stop him from destroying the
planet even further
now the other option is that superman
just goes and kills dark side
turns bad and then batman goes to the
joker after that in order to get the
mother box
i tend to lean more towards the former
vision as batman goes to get the
kryptonite in bbs
i think it's a bit of a fetch quest to
go get the mother box and then decide to
go and get the kryptonite either way
though he realizes that the world is
completely decimated
and with flash and cyborg they begin to
build the cosmic treadmill
batman then formulates two plans and the
first involves sending flash back to the
past to warn the heroes about going to
apocalypse
the second involves going to get the
rock to star in black adam
and save the dc eu no sir sorry the rock
of kryptonite
so that he can kill superman himself
should the time travel shenanigans fail
as we know it does and bruce is murdered
by superman
leading to a thousand years of darkness
however the flash traveling back in time
creates a new timeline
and this of course alters events even
further flash goes
back earlier than expected and in this
do-over he encounters bruce in the cave
which is where the nightmare premonition
first comes to be
the speed force works in mysterious ways
and
according to snyder when someone goes
back they also take elements with them
of the timeline that they're now erasing
and thus bruce is able to catch a
glimpse of the invasion
flash continues to travel through the
speed force and he eventually reaches
the correct position
which is when the group arrived on new
genesis just before they went to ambush
apocalypse
flash tells them not to strike at the
planet and because bruce has encountered
him before
he actually listens to the guy which is
what warner brothers should do
make the snyder cook cunning your fools
now unfortunately flash is ripped apart
in the time window
and his body gets thrown between the
future and past
at this point the nightmare timeline is
wiped out and this is why
you may see it being referred to as a
dream a sweet dream
or a beautiful nightmare batman
reformulates the plan and they decide to
travel back to earth to fight darkseid
on their terms instead
aware that lois is now the key to
keeping superman on the side of good
bruce hides her in the back cave rather
than at the lake house bruce develops a
weapon capable of killing darkseid
and when his armies arrive they're able
to push his forces back
in the middle of the battle lois goes
into labor and gives birth in the bat
cave
which is a bit inconvenient could you
could you not have waited
anyway unable to defeat superman
darkseid boom tubes into the cave in an
attempt to take the codex from the
newborn baby
so that he can create the equation
without having to fight earth's forces
before he's able to harvest the child
though batman steps between it and
darkseid
and fires the anti-god gun at him as it
hits him
darkseid fires in a mega beam which
kills batman in the process
however his sacrifice was in vain and
darkseid dies
freeing the world of his invasion
superman in the league mourn his death
and clark and lois named their child
jonathan bruce kent as a tribute to
their fallen friend
now i know i kind of went beyond the
nightmare stuff there but i didn't want
to leave the story half finished so
that's pretty much the original outline
and how the nightmare timeline plays
into it hope you had some fun and if you
have anything you'd like to add
then the comment box is yours do as you
please
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
throw on the 28th of february in which
we're giving away three copies of the
marvel phase 3 4k
box set to our subscribers all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
breakdown the winners of last month's
competition are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
justice league trailer which will be
linked on screen right now
we went over the entire thing from top
to bottom and it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
about the movie
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace